hey guys welcome back it's dr. Berg in
this video we're going to talk about a
very interesting hormone called growth
hormone okay now maybe you've heard
about growth hormone in different
animals where they inject the cow and
make them get bigger
we're not talking about that growth
hormone or sports enhancement where
they're using this illegally to improve
the performance we're not talking about
that we're talking about your body's
ability to make growth hormone now in a
child growth hormone is is there to make
you grow but once you're an adult it's
used to in other purposes mainly to help
preserve proteins okay now the question
is what part of your body is protein
well you got hair nails skin collagen
tendon ligaments even bone you have a
lot of your body protein so growth
hormone is the ultimate aging anti-aging
hormone because it preserves the skin
the tendons and it just keeps things
flexible and and if you're losing
protein if you're becoming more rigid
and the arteries you get high blood
pressure and you your body falls apart
so it's for cell growth cell
reproduction cell regeneration after
injury after stress it also helps you
retain calcium it's it's influenced with
cognitive function people that are low
in growth hormone have memory loss but I
think the other thing is that it's
really special in affecting fat burning
okay so if you growth hormone is the
main hormone that helps you burn fat so
if you don't have enough growth hormone
you become fat okay so now the question
is how can we get more of it
unfortunately at age 50 I mean it starts
crashing perhaps but 45 to 50 you start
getting lower levels of growth hormone
to the point where you're 60 and 70
becomes very very low as a child is very
high so we want to maintain as much of
this growth homeles as possible and
there are things that you can do to
naturally improve it so number one
intermittent fasting okay fasting and
intermittent fasting will increase
growth women which also means that you
know you
is concerned about losing muscle mass
well if you if you do intermittent
fasting you're going to enhance growth
hormones and protect your muscles from
being lost okay number two hypoglycemia
basically keeping your blood Sugar's low
because over here the things that lower
growth hormone is sugar so every time
you spike sugar or insulin you decrease
growth hormone so we want to keep the
growth hormone high we want to keep the
sugar very very low and out of the diet
okay arginine is an amino acid that will
also increase growth hormone arginine is
the is really prevalent in all types of
animal products animal meat products
okay animal proteins it's not really in
salad or nuts okay vitamin b3 will
increase growth hormone which is very
interesting
that's niacin and lastly intense
exercise that's the high intensity
interval training would be very vital to
enhance growth problem so if we combine
all these I mean you have ketosis in a
minute fasting interval training with
really keep the sugar out and you're
going to actually have some seriously
high growth hormone which you're going
to actually just slow down the aging
process now things that decrease growth
hormone would be insomnia not sleeping
sleep deprivation okay consuming sugar
and hidden sugar stress in cortisol
cortisol will worsen growth hormone and
then endocrine disruptors that would be
the pesticides and herbicides
insecticides all those interfere with
hormones okay and also especially the
growth hormones so I just wanted to
touch base on this very vital hormone so
go ahead and apply this information and
put your comments below